un grupo de detractores del aborto trata
de convencer a las pacientes que llegan
de que no interrumpan su embarazo
estamos aquí con un propósito
en contraposición maryló y su equipo de
voluntarios velan porque las mujeres
puedan entrar seguras al centro
asistencial Desde que la Corte Suprema
anuló el derecho al aborto en Estados
Unidos
como saben que muchas mujeres vienen a
la clínica de choices para su cita el
sábado que es el día que muchos no
trabajan vienen aquí cada sábado
estos voluntarios toman posición de
defensa para abrir las puertas a
pacientes a las que Marley Hoffman
asistirá para interrumpir sus embarazos
Si antes teníamos cinco o seis pacientes
al mes ahora Estamos recibiendo 15 a la
semana por la nueva ley y tenemos muchas
chicas y mujeres que vienen de Texas y
otros estados que han prohibido el
procedimiento
alexas el aborto se castiga con Prisión
De por vida por eso muchas mujeres
buscan tratamiento aquí donde la
seguridad es máxima en 1970 Hoffman
estableció uno de los primeros centros
del país cuando Nueva York legalizó el
aborto desde entonces en este estado se
permite interrumpir el embarazo hasta
las 24 semanas de gestación una ley que
atrae a pacientes realmente jóvenes
sí tenemos pacientes tan jóvenes como 11
o 12 años porque muchas veces son
Víctimas de violación o violadas en su
familia o abusadas
el procedimiento exige una gran
resiliencia y ronda los 3.000 dólares
por eso Hoffman habla de un nuevo
término aborcionó mix
sí vemos niñas Pero sabes muchos de
estos republicanos aman ver niñas
teniendo niños a pesar de los
detractores las clínicas de Nueva York
realizaron un 12% más de abortos en
cinco meses que en 2021 los expertos
aseguran que esta cifra podría aumentar
aún más ante la avalancha de mujeres
llegadas de otros estados más
restrictivos